[Music]
hi i'm max kuhn
i'm a statistician and work as a
software engineer at rstudio
i mostly focus on open source tools for
building models
i run the tidy models group and tiny
miles is a collection of our packages
that have very similar syntax and design
principles to the teddy bears
so we've made a lot of improvements to
tidy miles in the last six months some
of those improvements have been around
user interfaces so we have better ways
of specifying which predictors
are added to a model we've made other
improvements around computational
efficiency
so we have limited support now for
sparse matrices
and expanded support for parallel
processing now what i like to talk about
more in this video is a specific package
that we just released called fine tune
and fine tune is an expansion of our
tune package and gives two additional
ways to optimize hyper parameters or
tuning parameters and models
now those are types of parameters that
can't be directly estimated from the
data
such as the number of neighbors and the
k nearest neighbor model
and so one variation we'll look at in
this presentation
is a new method of doing grid search and
the other method is a
another iterative method called
simulated annealing
to illustrate the methods that we'll
talk about today we'll use the cell
segmentation data from the model data
package
it's a two class classification problem
with about 58 numeric
predictors we use the support vector
machine
and for the support vector machine
there's a variety of tuning parameters
such as the cost value or the radio
basis function kernel parameter called
sigma
and then this talk will be about two
different ways of finding optimal
parameters of these values
now these these tuning parameter values
are important they have a big influence
on the model fit
and performance the problem is we can't
directly estimate them from the data
so we need to find good ways of coming
up with values for those
those two parameters even though we
can't directly estimate them
to measure performance we'll use 10-fold
cross-validation
and we'll measure the air into the rc
curve now the model definitions and the
complete code set that you can use to
reproduce these analyses are shown at
the link here
so to give some visual demonstration of
what we're trying to do what i did is it
took these two different tuning
parameters and generated a very large
grid
and resampled them and that gives a
sense of what the the truly best result
would be
from our search and you can see here on
the left hand side this contour plot
blue values indicate poor performance of
the roc curve
and then white values are more optimal
and so you can see
the lower diagonal the search space is
it's pretty flat
and not very good and as you go to the
upper diagonal there's sort of like a
little mountainous ridge
that has good performance values and the
best performance value on the left hand
side plot
is shown by the the black dot and any
really uh
point along the ridge that goes from
that black dot sort of down towards the
southeast uh would give us pretty good
performance the problem is if we go
over that ridge uh that dark spot there
which you can see a little bit better on
the right hand side
surface plot gives really really poor
performance
so we want to find the values of these
tuning parameters
and we'll be trying to find the the best
ones which are indicated in the white on
the plots
now the first method we'll talk about is
something called racing methods
and this is sort of an alteration of
grid search that's been around for quite
a while
now in orderly ordinary grid search what
you would do is come up with a candidate
set of parameter values that you want to
try and then you'd measure the
performance usually using resampling
and then pick the one that seems to be
best or gives you has the
characteristics that you like
now the problem with this is you have to
evaluate a potentially large number of
models to get performance estimates
until you can make a decision so let's
say we do 20 values of the support
vector machine
tuning parameters and when we use
10-fold cross-validation
that would be about 200 total model fits
and we can't make a decision
on which training parameters are good or
bad until we do all that work
so what racing methods do is they sort
of incrementally evaluate three samples
so in the first couple resamples you
proceed as normal and measure their
performance
and then what you do subsequently is do
an interim analysis
after each resample to figure out
basically are there tuning parameters
that have a low probability of being
called the best results
and so one way we could do that is we
could fit an anova model to those
results
where the outcome is let's say the error
into the rc curve
or whatever performance metric you want
to want to use
and the predictive factor is the the
qualitative
um tuning parameter combinations like
you know model 1 model 12 and so on
so what we can do is we can evaluate
those and see which ones are
statistically
different from the best possible and if
they are we can discard them
now there's another there's a variety of
ways to do racing methods we have a
second one implemented in fine tune
that uses wind law statistics on
something called the bradley terry model
and treats these data as if they were
sports competition
if you want to learn more about these
methods and particularly how we
implemented them here
there's a paper there from 2014 that has
the details and for our particular
example we'll use a grid of 20
support vector machine candidate values
that are generated with space-filling
design and we'll show how raising can be
used to efficiently evaluate them
compared to ordinary grid search
so let's illustrate the rays so let's
say we take our 10 folds and we randomly
arrange them so they're in a random
order we would take the first fold
and do what we normally do we'd compute
our
our models and then make predictions and
measure let's say the area of the rc
curve
now in the plot what you see is on the
the y-axis
is just the model number uh which are
just sort of arbitrarily numbered
there's 20 of them
and on the x-axis we see the measure of
performance and so the blue dot for
model 12
indicates that it had the best
performance across all the tuning
perimeter values
and then the rest of the points show the
loss of performance
compared to the current best so you can
see model 12 was the current best but
model 17 was close behind
and on the bottom there model 16 did not
have very good performance
and so this is after we've evaluated the
first free sample
now in the second resample we do the
same thing we just resample
and compute the the performance metrics
for all 20 tuning perimeter values
now in this plot instead of the
individual rc values this is
these points represent the average of
two uh
roc area under the curve values for each
model
now perform the lead leaders switch from
model 12 to model 17
but you can still see that there's a
variety of different models
that do not have very good performance
compared to those
now in iteration three we start doing
the interim analysis in this case we're
going to be talking about the anova
method
and what that allows us to do is put a
confidence interval on the loss of
performance
compared to the leader for each tuning
parameter value and so you can see the
ones that are in black
are there's no evidence to reject that
they're statistically different from the
best value in blue
but the ones in gray that you can see
are statistically different from that
and therefore we think it would be
pretty good idea to discard them from
further consideration
so basically we use the nerve statistics
to figure out which tuning parameter
values
to keep resampling and which ones we can
get rid of in this particular case in
the third iteration we're getting rid of
17 different tuning perimeter values
now on iteration four the confidence
intervals tighten up pretty considerably
and uh
model one there falls out to where we're
left with two models
and as we keep resampling you can see
that you know we're getting closer and
closer to having one fall out
and then iteration 9 of 10 model 12
finally is discarded because it's not
statistically
or because it is statistically different
than the best so this is on the ninth
fold out of 10. what we normally do is
if we have any
situation where there's only one left
over we keep resampling it so it has the
full precision
that we would like to measure
performance so
after nine iterations basically we
filter out all but one tuning value
combination
and then we just resample model 17 once
and what the result is instead of
fitting the full set of 200 model fits
we actually considered 74 model fits so
it's a pretty substantial reduction
in both time and evaluations of models
and since our inner analysis method is
not very slow
we're able to call these values pretty
quickly
and so the nice thing about racing is is
you can do a very large grid if you'd
like
and do it pretty efficiently because you
chances are you will not be resampling
the full grid for all of the possible
resamples
the code for racing is shown here is
very similar to the tuned grid function
in the tune package and you can see that
we first set the seed so we make sure we
get reproducible results
and then what we do is run the tune race
anova function
its arguments are very very similar to
tuned grid the relevant one that's shown
here is the grid argument and that could
either be an integer that says
basically how many tuning parameter
combinations you want to evaluate and
let the
function figure out which to do or you
could pass in a data frame there that
has the exact combinations that you're
interested in
there's a control argument that lets you
specify a lot of the numerical aspects
of things like
the size of the confidence interval
that's used for elimination and so on
there's also a verbose alim option that
does some logging that shows you the
progress as you proceed
so you can see there it shows that we
eliminated 17 tuning parameter values at
the first iteration and so on
now if you'd like to try the other
racing method that's based on wind loss
statistics
that function is called tune race win
loss and the syntax is identical to what
we see here in tune racinoma
so as i mentioned racing is really a
grid search method
that's done very efficiently and again
in grid search you predefined all the
values you want to look at
so the next method we'll talk about is
an iterative search method based on
simulated annealing
where new values are determined after
each
current value so you don't predefine the
tuning parameter values
so simulating is really a pretty old
search routine
and it conducts a biased random walk
around our tuning parameter space
and the bias comes in because once it
creates a new
tuning parameter candidate and evaluates
it
it may discard that from the search and
pretend like it never existed
or if the results are not too far from
optimal
or a new best it would accept that and
proceed from there
so we'll show that in detail in a little
bit as we as we show the example
one thing we should talk about is how
simulating comes up with its next value
to evaluate
so on the right hand side we sort of
have a plot where the black line shows a
search that's gone through six
iterations
and it's slowly going down towards the
the bottom uh right
and then once we are at that last point
we need to generate
values that are within a local
neighborhood of the current best
so what simulator kneeling would do
would find values that are not too
different from the one you're currently
evaluating
so what we've done is we've um generated
a variety of random combinations that
are shown in red there
that are within some sort of radius
around the current best and then we
would select one from random as the next
point that we should evaluate
now the bias random walk part comes in
because if we select one of those and
the performance is not as good as the
current value
we have two choices the other algorithm
can either accept it and proceed from it
going forward or discard it and again
pretend as if
it was never generated and the
determining factors
for whether we discard or accept a
result are based on two things
one is how early you are in the search
process so you're much more likely to
accept sub-optimal values at the early
parts of the search
progress that's how simulated kneeling
works
and as you get to the later iterations
you're much less likely
to accept poor values now the second
factor
in that decision is how bad was the
current result
so if the current result is just
slightly worse than the current best
it's more likely that you would accept
it but if it's a really awful point
probabilistically it's less likely that
you would consider that
as the current point and base your next
point off of that one
so we'll show this in some detail with
our current example
so here's our search base that we looked
at earlier i've generated a grid of four
different
tuning parameter values and evaluated
them using resampling
the current best from that grid is the
green dot
so simulated annealing will start from
that green dot and proceed from there
so on the first iteration we're going to
define again this neighborhood around
that green dot
and randomly generate a point and so we
did that it actually turns out it's a
new best it's going towards the better
results
and so we keep that and then base the
iteration two results
on this value now in iteration two
we go in kind of a poor direction and
get actually fairly bad results
and they're low enough to where we would
discard this as being sub-optimal
and so when we go to iteration three
it's based on results from iteration one
as you'll see in just a second
so discarding it means we do not use it
to generate the next point in the search
so in iteration three you see we get
another new best
and then we can keep going around the
search by finding things in a local
neighborhood
now one of the things about simulated
annealing is it's a global search method
which means
it can go back and reevaluate areas that
it might have already evaluated
and so in this particular result on
iteration eight it goes back in a
different direction
and we accepted a sub-optimal and as you
can see we're going to go
into an area that's not very good and
we're getting a series of just poor
results
now simulating kneeling also has this
feature where you can do a restart
so if you don't have good results within
a certain number of iterations
you can trigger the search to start from
its last known best point
and proceed from there and that is
actually what happens here
that we still have another sub-optimal
result and then we start the search
again from the current best
and so we proceed along here it happens
again
we go off in a bad direction and then
restart
and so you can see we're close to the
number of iterations so i did 30
iterations here
and it would just continue to look until
it finds
uh better and better values so that's a
little graphical representation of how
simulated annealing works
if you want to use this in code the code
is very similar to the tune based
function
in the tune package the arguments are
almost all the same
you could tell a number of iterations to
proceed from
again there's another control parameter
that determines things like
the size of the local neighborhood and
so on so it has some of the numerical
properties that you can tweak
for simulated annealing it also has a
verbose method so if you set that to
true
you get some nice logging as the search
continues
uh what's nice about this is if you're
running interactively
and it's been running for a while and
you feel like maybe it's done as best as
it could do
you can mainly interrupt the execution
of the the tuned seminal function
and it will return all the results that
it's achieved so far
so by manually interrupting it you don't
lose all the results that you've
generated
it will give you the ones that you've um
completed
to date and so that's the other function
that we wanted to show for uh model
tuning
in the fine tune package if you want to
learn more look at tidy models.org
especially if you're new to tidy models
that has a lot of articles on getting
started
a nice sequence of examples of how to
use recipes and parsnip and variety of
different things
there's other articles there for people
who have used it
where in more advanced articles that
show different aspects of tidy models
julia silke and i are also writing a
book on tidy models it's about halfway
done
at the end of 2020. chapter 13 is about
grid search and it has more details
about racing
and chapter 14 is about iterative search
and one of the things it describes there
is simulated kneeling
you can also look at the fine tune
webpage which has a nice formatted
reference section as well as the blog
post that we used to to launch the
package
thanks for watching and i hope you enjoy
it